alors comment réduire les dépenses
publiques c'est difficile c'est vrai
c'est difficile c'est difficile pour
tous les gouvernements et nous avons un
certain nombre d'idées précises la
première c'est d'abord d'instaurer une
forme de sobriété bureaucratique on
parle beaucoup de ce briété énergétique
mais il y a une autre sobriété qu'il
faudrait être instauré c'est celle d'une
bureaucratie et devenue complètement
surabondante
vous savez Emmanuel Macron lui-même
disait de l'État français qu'il était
obèse et malvoyant donc il a fait le
constat comme souvent mais il n'en a pas
tiré les conclusions et c'est tout à
fait regrettable donc ce briété
bureaucratique dont on espère beaucoup
réduction des normes parce que les
normes ça crée de la bureaucratie ça
crée du contrôle ça crée de la lourdeur
administrative cette lourdeur
administrative cette complexité
administrative il faut il faut
l'administrer
et ça coûte très cher